well i may not seem to be the biggest
champion of diversity but i could still
appreciate watching a glass ceiling get
shattered as much as any progressive the
truth is that despite appearances you
know i do deeply value diversity equity
inclusion tolerance
i know that this country has come so far
in atoning for the sins of its past and
yet it still has so much farther to go
and that's why i nearly wept with tears
of joy this morning as i heard the news
that an african-american man may soon
take ownership of twitter we we inched
ever closer to true and complete racial
equity in this country when elon musk
positioned himself to potentially become
the first african-american immigrant to
own a major social media platform this
is this is big news big progress kataji
brown jackson's confirmation
may have been an historic achievement
but it pales in comparison to this
as the daily wire reports elon musk the
tech billionaire who made waves across
the world after recently becoming the
largest twitter shareholder is offering
to buy 100 of twitter at 54.20
per share in a cash deal that could
exceed 40 billion according to an sec
filing submitted wednesday evening musk
told twitter chairman brett taylor that
this was his best and final offer the
offer comes just days after musk
declined to take a position on twitter's
board of directors
and now we know why he declined to take
that position
um you can read in the sec filing the
voice and text message from musk to
twitter where he explains his offer he
emphasizes again that he's not going to
negotiate it's his best and final
but if the board doesn't accept the
offer which i don't know how they could
choose not to accept as declining the
offer would be them acting against the
financial interests of their
shareholders
but if they don't accept musk indicated
that he would reconsider quote-unquote
his position as a shareholder uh so this
is in other words a hostile takeover and
certainly if they refuse the offer and
musk pulls out completely twitter's
stock price is going to plummet through
the floor
so they're backed into a corner it would
seem and it is a glorious sight to
behold
now as for the reaction to this news it
has been as you might expect
quite dramatic
some of us though see this as you know
not only a major win for racial equity
but also an opportunity for example i've
already reached out to elon on twitter
and offered my services as the company's
new chief diversity and inclusion
officer i assume there's going to be a
lot of vacancies coming up especially in
those kinds of departments and i am
willing to do that i don't even need a
seven figure income to do the job i'd
settle for something even in just like
the high six figure range
but the left has not been quite so
hopeful or optimistic they are treating
this like the end of the world literally
i mean somebody tweeted this morning
quote elon musk buying twitter is the
end of the world basically he'll amplify
every extremist right-wing nazi he can
find
the verified left-wing blue checks on
the platform especially are having a
difficult time we're going to read some
of these and i think we might need some
sad piano music again for this
lance richardson says
elon musk buying twitter if he's indeed
successful might be the impetus i've
been looking for to delete this thing
permanently
there's a lot of that by the way people
threatening to leave leftist threatening
to leave
it's like one of those is that a threat
or a promise kind of thing
max boot says
i'm frightened by the impact on society
and politics if elon musk acquires
twitter he seems to believe that on
social media anything goes
for democracy to survive we need more
content moderation not less
just stop and think about that for a
second for democracy to survive we need
more content moderation
for democracy to survive there needs to
be less ability to express
your point of view
makes sense whitney don carlson says
more simply f you elon musk
and then miguel an employee of twitter
says
i can't even with elon buying twitter i
may have to rethink my employment if
that actually happens
and pam keith says i love you all but i
am 100
out if musk takes over twitter no pam
keith keith don't leave please we beg
you to stay
well you know what actually call this
whole thing off i just decided i thought
it was good but if pam keith
is not going to be on twitter with elon
musk in control then forget the whole
thing it's not worth it
um matthew rosa desperately beseeched
the current ceo of twitter to resist the
takeover attempt he tweeted dear perag
agrawal if you're reading this right now
the world needs to know that you're
stronger smarter and more tenacious than
elon musk
he thinks he can beat you
the free world needs to know that he's
wrong
yours truly a lifelong and long verified
twitter user
that's also how that's how i sign all of
my letters as well actually as it
happens um don't ask either of us how we
could possibly be lifelong twitter users
that's it that's irrelevant
and then finally of course jeff jarvis
pushes the nazi button in case of
emergency push the nazi button which
it's like it's always an emergency for
the left so he says today on twitter
feels like the last evening in a berlin
nightclub at the twilight of weimer
germany
[Music]
yes
the prospect that people expressing
their of people expressing their
opinions honestly on twitter
is exactly like
nazi germany
people being able to tweet
memes with abandon
it's just like nazism there's no
difference really
now
jokes somewhat aside
i think i do think there are two
important points to be made about this
um aside from the fact that
elon musk is an african-american man
which by the way like that will never
not be hilarious to say i don't care how
many times the joke is used it's not
even really jokes that's technically
true
it that's just the gr that's one of my
favorite honestly one of my favorite
facts
in the universe actually is that elon
musk is an african-american because they
hate him so much and he's like the
richest guy in the world and he's and it
makes them so mad when you call him an
african-american but they can't it's
true so they can't do anything about it
i just i love it anyway
um so the first thing to keep in mind
here is that as happy as i am about elon
musk potentially seizing the reins of
twitter
and as delighted as i am to drink from
such an abundance of leftist tears so
many tears that my my tumbler can can't
possibly hold them all
i do however think that we should
acknowledge that it's not a good sign
that we're relying on the benevolence of
an eccentric billionaire to protect the
free exchange of ideas
you know if you had any doubt before
this is now all the confirmation you
should need that we we do live in an
oligarchy ours is a country fully in the
hands of a group of elites in government
media and the corporate world pushing
and pulling and conspiring with each
other and sometimes fighting with each
other to control our lives
that's that's the world we live in it's
not a good system
but since we're stuck in it for now the
best thing that can happen within the
system is that at least one of these
powerful people decides that free speech
is actually important
and seizes control of a platform like
twitter to provide a forum for it
second we have to ask
why exactly is the left panicking so
much at the thought of elon musk taking
control of twitter
um the answer is obvious but worth
articulating in any case
musk is not despite how he's portrayed
some sort of right-wing ideologue he's
not going to go in and start banishing
all the leftist accounts out into the
hinterlands as satisfying as that might
be to see
from a retribution kind of perspective
but he's not going to do that and
everyone knows he's not going to do that
the fear on the left is
not that they'll be banished
but that musk will make good on his
promise to allow the free and open
expression of opinions and ideas
leftism's cultural dominance relies
heavily
almost entirely on the control of
expression
it hasn't taken this position of
dominance by
defeating the other side in the
ideological arena it hasn't convinced
people to come over to its camp it
hasn't made like convincing arguments
and people say oh wow you know i've
considered both points of view and uh
sure
its ideas cannot prevail in that kind of
contest
they don't stand up against even the
slightest scrutiny
so for leftism the game is won by making
sure that it is the only team allowed on
the field
this kind of suppression accomplishes i
think two things for them one
it of course ensures that people don't
encounter the opposing views or hear the
arguments and because you don't need to
bother debunking or defeating arguments
that nobody hears anyway
very often people come up to me
and uh they'll like thank me for making
some point or another and and then
they'll tell me that oh you know i'd
never heard that before i never heard
anyone put it like that before and
that's always shocking to me because all
i ever do
is state the obvious i i have no deeper
insights to offer really and yet
um
and don't quote me on that you know
because you're still watching the show
but really what i'm doing is just
stating the obvious and yet even obvious
truths are kept out of view from so many
people
the other thing that suppression
accomplishes i think even more so is
isolation
um this is another thing that i hear all
the time for people because if it's
common sense it means that it's a lot of
these things are the kinds of things
people know you don't need to tell them
they just know it
like that you know men and women are
different for example it's a common
sense thing it's self-evident
maybe one of the most self-evident facts
in the world
and so everyone kind of knows you don't
need to tell them that
and yet the other thing that i get from
people they'll come and they'll thank me
for expressing some opinion
uh or another because prior to hearing
me say it they thought that they were
alone in thinking that way
or nearly alone
and this is always surprising too
because again you know it's common sense
but leftist speech suppression has made
it so that people with normal common
sense ideas about the world
feel like they are alone
and after a while if you think you're
alone
in feeling a certain way or thinking a
certain way or having a certain opinion
you might surrender to the mainstream
view just for the sake of
self-preservation
or you might convince yourself that you
must be wrong
given that you're so
outnumbered this is the process that's
actually happened with some people on
the gender issue
and a lot sometimes it also is dependent
some in some ways on where you live
um
but
people are so surrounded by this
insanity that after a while they start
to think well am i am i wrong about this
i thought men and women are different
but everywhere i go and
everyone seems to be affirming the
opposite
so this is a very valuable tool to the
left and it's what they stand to lose
at least partially if twitter slips out
of their hands and it's why they're
panicking
and it's why it's so enjoyable to behold
and besides if you're on the left
and you're worried about this what's the
big deal remember what you always told
us
just go build your own twitter
it's not hard to do
so good luck
hey listen
hit the subscribe button do it right now
i demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat appreciated